well coaches on the voice are certainly
in search of the real thing and thanks
are a little bit different for Blake
Shelton and Gwen Stefani they both went
through big breakups but Tamara Madison
found out at least they have each other
rolled up and everything ready right off
the bat Blake was messing with me and
despite his divorce from Miranda he's
got backup are you guys supportive of
each other well we're friends I haven't
met one coach that's been on this show
that I'm not that I wouldn't consider at
this point a really good friend I mean
any of the coaches that I've worked with
on this show I can call it at any moment
and talk to or he's right
and with her summer split from Gavin
after nearly 13 years Gwen seems happy
to be focused on work when you've said
that you couldn't wait to get back to
the show season nine how does it feel
it's so amazing honestly I've I've had
so much fun so far and it's so
motivating and I think this is probably
the funnest thing I've ever done an
outsider in my whole life like work-wise
this group on the voice is a family a
family that just keeps growing when we
first are doing the voice person had at
that point it was Jackson yeah right
yeah and and it was really it was like a
like a little daycare
play pants and like I was like whoa and
I was still like barely 30 and I was
like
you